I lost about 12 pounds in a week and my
numbers went sky-high much higher than
they were when I was first diagnosed so
the doctors have decided that I have to
undergo chemo again today on Good
Morning America Alex gives a
disheartening update on his treatment
for Stage four pancreatic cancer I was
doing so well and my numbers went down
to the equivalent of a normal human
being who does not have pancreatic
cancer so we were all very optimistic in
fact the beloved Jeopardy host told fans
just last month the things were looking
up I'm on the mend now the TV icon says
his illness has taken its toll both
physically occasionally it will cause
excruciating pain in my lower back other
times it's fatigue other times it's
nausea and emotionally there are moments
when for no reason at all I feel this
surge of sadness depression doesn't last
very long but it just takes over my
whole being for a short period of time
but regardless of his diagnosis he says
he is at peace with whatever comes his
way I've had one hell of a good life and
I've enjoyed it and the thought of
passing on doesn't frighten me all right
let's go to work good luck players and
in a new message from the Jeopardy set
he says he's still optimistic that the
chemo will do its job hey they work very
well the first time so we're expecting
good results again but please keep me in
your good thoughts and prayers
believe me it means a lot
[Music]